how much time should a filmmaker expect
to put into distribution
versus pre-production or production
great question so i i
in my world in my experience having made
seven features
takes me about a year to make the movie
by the time i'm i'm talking from idea
to final delivery that's about a year
so there's about a month or two
in idea development stage there's
probably
two to three months in financing there
is
a month or two in pre-production there
is a month or two in production and then
there's you know
i didn't do the math on it probably
about six months in post-production
and delivery so that's the production
phase
distribution minimum
well it's see distribution is not
full-time production what i just
described is full-time
you're maybe not development isn't
full-time where you're working on 100 of
the time but
but production certainly is and
post-production if you're doing your own
edit you know certainly is right
um distribution is full-time
when you're at markets and and when
you're preparing and everything there's
about
i'm gonna say four to five months of
full-time
prep for distribution getting well mind
you if you've done it many times you
have all your lists all together and you
know who your customers are and you're
prepping your materials and
hopefully your trailer is already made
from production i always cut my trailer
first before i cut my movie
and yeah because you need to have a
trailer you change it as you go along
too um
but um artwork and and um whatever
you know presentation materials you want
to have you don't need a ton you just
have some photos and stuff like that
and then you spend you know the first
four to five months putting it out to
the marketplace
um perhaps going to a market and we'll
talk about markets first festivals in a
second
and then you know and soliciting it to
whoever your lists are if oh this is
self-distribution by the way
if you're doing through a distributor
then you're putting it out to
distributors
and you you want to put it out to you
know i'm going to say 25 to 50
distributors if
if you can that's what seems like a lot
but uh
you know when you have your short list
of say top 10 who you really really care
about
and then you put it out to all these
other ones and it's not just american if
you're an american producer you don't
just put them out to american
distributors
there's tons of distributors in uk
australia you know who all speak english
and
who do worldwide distribution so the
world is you know
is a big place now and you can deal
pretty well in any country
but then distribution goes on for you
know three to four years
i mean it goes on your whole life really
i mean as long as you own your film
it's you know as long as your asset is
in existence and you haven't sold it
and it's yours then you technically can
monetize it the rest of your life
that's what they call library rights i
mean you're just hopefully continuing to
monetize it
it's not as active and robust
generally the second or third time
around you know after
the first year is when most of the sales
happen or the first
yeah the first 12 to 24 months most of
your sales are going to happen
if people want to buy it it's it takes
customers used to take them like three
to four months to make a decision now it
takes them like
six to eight months it's amazing you
think here's a film
watch it do you want it or you don't
want it you think that should take an
evening right
it takes a long time these lead times
are a long time you have to have a lot
of patience
but generally within the first two years
you're going to have exhausted all
or your distributor will have exhausted
all of the sales contacts
and done what i call round one made all
the rounds gotten all the answers back
and you know if that's sold or not
and then after that again it's your
asset and you
it never ends and deliverables are done
by the filmmaker or if you get a
distributor they will do
some of the deliverable work so here's
the thing
the distributor definitely will do the
deliverables but you will pay them to do
the deliverables
everything the distributor does you're
going to pay for and not only will you
pay for the actual physical
deliverable but you will pay a fee for
them to do that
because it costs them time and you know
effort to do it
so for instance let's say let's use dubs
okay let's say you have to do language
dubs
right they distribute themselves is
aren't going to make the language dubs
they don't do that they don't have you
know in-house dubbing facilities
maybe one or two do but most of them
don't okay they're gonna go to an
outside third party dubbing company you
know who makes
language versioning and they're gonna
hire them
and they're gonna tell them exactly what
they need to do and then they're gonna
let them do it
and they're gonna pay a fee to them to
do it
and the distributor's going to negotiate
that fee and then
they're going to pay the fee to them and
then they're going to charge it back to
you through the revenue that comes back
to your film
but in addition to the fee they paid to
the versioning company they're also
going to take
a fee for themselves for managing it
maybe
an additional 10 20 so let's say there's
a hundred thousand dollars in language
dubbing
the distributor might add on another you
know fifteen to twenty thousand dollars
in their labor to manage that process so
the bill you're gonna get
is a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
as opposed to a hundred thousand dollars
if you
put it out to the same versioning
company yourself
but if you were to do that then one you
need to know
what versioning companies to go to and
who to ask and make sure you do the
do it the proper way and get the right
companies on board because
you know versioning is a very particular
thing
and two you have to have the cash flow
because now the version income is gonna
charge you a hundred thousand dollars
and you need to pay them a hundred
thousand cash the distributor
has the cash they'll pay the hundred
thousand on your behalf but it'll cost
you an extra twenty thousand but
it's often worth it because you don't
have the cash are some of these bills
from the distributor
set against potential profit or will you
actually get a bill in the mail
that you're like needing to write a
check for so it's
with a good distribution deal everything
should be
recouped against revenue not profit
revenue
so as revenue comes in the way the way
most distribution deals work is
um it's called a waterfall all right so
revenue comes in
so let me use a hundred dollars make it
real simple okay
a hundred dollars comes in the door if
they're working on a thirty percent fee
then the first thirty dollars goes to
them of the hundred
to the distributor all right then
if they have costs of say twenty
twenty dollars then the next twenty
dollars comes off of that to pay for
their costs
all right so now they take that they
recoup their costs so now there's 50
left then if they have given you say a
minimum guarantee
of 10 right then they're going to recoup
that so they paid you 10 already so
they're going to take the 10 back
so now there's they've taken 60 there's
40 dollars left
and then you're gonna get that forty
dollars
that's how that works so probably okay
well yeah
i forgot to say okay now let's say let's
say that
they have costs of seventy dollars
so they took eighty dollars let's say
eighty dollars
so they took third because there was
languaging versioning right
so the 100 came in and
they took thirty dollars as their fee
but their costs were actually
call it ninety dollars they spent to
make some languaging versions
but there's only seventy dollars less so
they take the not they take
the red seventy but you still owe them
twenty dollars they're still out of
pocket twenty dollars
so the question is did they send you a
bill for twenty dollars
and the answer is hopefully not
hopefully they wait until the next
revenue comes in
because that's the way a good
distribution deal should have been
negotiated
but maybe they do i mean filmmakers have
told me they've gotten those kind of
bills they shouldn't
it should be against the revenue that's
coming in but
sometimes they do is there language
that one should look out for to make
sure that it's
set against potential revenue of course
there is a hundred percent there's
language
there's language for everything and you
have to be super particular with your
language
i mean that's that's why you need
somebody who knows what they're doing to
make sure your language is proper
and there and the distributors play
games with the language all lawyers play
games with language
what do you mean by it purposely
confusing people
remember i said it before distributors
in business to make money
their job isn't to rip off the next
person but it's to do the best deal that
they possibly can
so you need to make sure that your jobs
do the best deal you can for yourself
just you know you don't know as much as
they do
so make sure you get somebody who does
know so that you can make sure that you
address all those issues to your benefit
or at least
make them fair and so they're not skewed
in their favor
should one be afraid of a short contract
a short term on the contract no just in
terms of like it's only
one page and and really one that's more
elaborate
is actually more beneficial no i don't
know
the substantive deal terms depending on
the size of the font can fit onto one
page
oh okay and there's about seven or eight
substantive deal terms and
they generally can fit onto one page i
call those deal memos
or you know i mean that's or that's more
or less what we call them deal memos
and often i mean most of my distribution
contracts are only two pages
and then the last paragraph the last
sentence says
um a long form will follow if the you
know
there's option for the long form to
follow
the long form which you know is 40 to 50
pages
is a lot of legal jargon built up over
years and years and years
it's a lot of accounting and and
termination
language which is super important but
often a deal member will say you know
and the rest of the terms per industry
standard for reasonable industry
standard
um then you know sometimes you'll attach
an addendum to it
but you need a deal memo at first the
major
terms are you know how long the deal is
going to be
that's the period or the term the period
right
um what the royalty level is going to be
like what their fees
either what their fee is going to be
what they're going to take or how much
they're going to give you
their costs what their costs are going
to be are they capped
is there i put in a performance
threshold are there performance
thresholds
what the territory is going to be like
where they're selling it for
what the rights are are you giving them
all the rights or just um certain rights
you know just for certain
you know broadcast or streaming or
whatever um
is it exclusive or non-exclusive and
what the language is going to be
when you say language mean language of
languages of languages and who's going
to do transcripts or dubbing
no it's just what language rights you're
giving them and then you'll figure that
all out in costs and everything yeah and
then you'd probably put down okay who's
yeah you'd probably say who's gonna
who's gonna incur this
and does a distributor um have the right
to change the name of the
like the title of the film if they feel
that in a certain territory
it will do better or they that they have
the right if you give them the right
it's your choice if you want to grant
them that right they'll tell you you
should grant them because they know
better and that will help market the
film better
and in a lot of cases i would agree with
that but they only have the right if you
grant it to them
they don't have any rights other than
what you negotiate
it's all and that's why deal memos are
very long and complicated
because over the years there's been a
lot of stuff negotiated that lawyers
tend to put
in we call those boilerplate clauses
over and over and over
if this happens then that happens then
this happens and you know it depends who
drafted the contract
generally a distributor wants to use a
contract that they drafted
because they trusted and they negotiated
it over the years and they built it over
the years
they're not too receptive for you
bringing in your own distribution
contract
because it won't be as generally as
favorable to them
or they have to spend a lot of time
reviewing it to make sure that it's
fair and the best is you know the
netflix contract
i love netflix they're actually super
reasonable believe it or not
they actually care about filmmakers
which you'd be surprised but they do
um but there's no negotiating i mean the
lawyer said to me on the business
affairs person who's a lawyer on the
other side said
and you know and i said i'm going to do
my own legals because i'm a lawyer and
i'm
confident that i know what i'm doing
she said is there anything like you'd
like to address and i said
if there was would it matter and she
said
kind of not
[Laughter]
you